sie sollen es richten
die spd mitglieder haben entschieden sie
wollen saskia esken und norbert walter
borjans als parteichefs nach dem
anschlag in london
der attentäter war ein verurteilter
terrorist und wurde vorzeitig aus dem
gefängnis entlassen
knaller gruppe für löws team bei der em
musste die deutsche mannschaft gegen
weltmeister frankreich und europameister
portugal rannten die nachrichten des
tages heute mit petra gestalten abend
willkommen an einem innenpolitisch
ereignisreichen nachrichten samstag aber
auch der sport hat ja einiges zu bieten
heute in kürze mit norbert könig neben
der auslosung auch noch ein bisschen
wintersport genommen ein halbes jahr war
die spd auf der suche nach neuen
parteichefs heute ist sie fündig
geworden
die mitglieder bestimmten saskia esken
und norbert walter borjans zu
nachfolgern für andrea nahles
die beiden bekamen in der stichwahl mit
rund 53 prozent acht prozentpunkte mehr
als ihre konkurrenten klara geywitz und
olaf scholz vizekanzler und
finanzminister klaus bonsack
seit dem frühen morgen wurde ausgezählt
in der spd-zentrale rund 425.000
mitglieder waren aufgerufen ihre stimme
online oder per briefwahl abzugeben
am ende beteiligten sich 54 prozent eine
eher ernüchternde zahl der vorsprung des
sieger duos allerdings ist überraschend
auch saskia esken norbert walter borjans
entfielen 11 11 114 1995 stimmen das
sind 53 06 sie also sollen die spd
künftig führen saskia esken und norbert
walter borjans er ehemaliger
finanzminister in nordrhein-westfalen
sie abgeordnete im bundestag hinter uns
allen liegen jetzt drei lange monate mit
bewerbung des schönste amt nach papst
die hier jemand gesagt hat und das jetzt
stehen nominiert für den mitgliedern das
ist wirklich ziemlich großartig vielen
vielen dank ich fand dass wir uns mal
kontroversen geliefert haben gezeigt
haben aber dass das immer in einem stil
war der das begründet hat was in der
zukunft jetzt auch folgen muss dass wir
bei diesem ergebnis dass wir jetzt
erzielt haben dafür sorgen müssen dass
wir zusammenbleiben nicht nur wir
sondern auch die menschen die euch
unterstützt haben die uns unterstützt
haben ein ende der großen koalition ist
jetzt zumindest wahrscheinlicher
geworden es können und walter borjans
liebäugeln mit einem austritt aus der
regierung unklar auch ob olaf scholz
nach dieser niederlage finanzminister
bleibt die verlierer sichern jedenfalls
den gewinnern ihre unterstützung zu ich
glaube die spd hat eine entscheidung
getroffen die entscheidung bedeutet eine
neue parteiführung und hinter der müssen
sich jetzt alle versammeln das ist das
was für die spd in der zukunft wichtig
ist damit wir eine starke partei werden
tatsächlich dürfte eine der wichtigsten
aufgaben der neuen vorsitzenden seien
die weitere spaltung der spd zu
verhindern
der frage an theo koll im willy brandt
haus in berlin theo kann das neue
führungsduo die partei nun konsolidieren
oder wird doch eine art spaltung
zurückbleiben
ja sind nach den sechs monaten der
führung suche und des wettstreits ist
die partei natürlich spürbar gespalten
hat das auch hier am jubel der beiden
lager klar erkennen können alle haben
sofort den zusammenhalt betont und dass
alle auch die verlierer dafür arbeiten
werden aber ganz so unwahrscheinlich ist
das auch nicht denn bei 13 prozent in
den umfragen haben ja beide lager im
prinzip ihre probleme mit der großen
koalition werden auch beide lager zu
unterschiedlichen schlüssen kommen für
oder gegen die gruppe hätte die wahl nun
für die zukunft der regierung
ich glaube das ist von dramatischer
bedeutung was wir heute hier eben erlebt
haben denn die neue spd spitze steht
sehr kritisch zur koalition mit der
union beide werden in einem leitantrag
für den parteitag ihre zusatzforderungen
stellen beispielsweise mehr klimaschutz
massive investitionen möglicherweise
einen höheren mindestlohn von 12 euro
und dann wird sich zeigen ob das für die
union überhaupt tragbar ist also es
werden bewegte zeiten hier für die
bundesregierung ein vorzeitiges ende der
koalition ist jedenfalls
wahrscheinlicher geworden die
einschätzung von theo koll vielen dank
dafür nach berlin
der wettstreit um die neue spd-spitze
ist entschieden welche herausforderungen
jetzt auf das neue führungsduo zu kommen
und weitere hintergründe finden sie
online auf heute.de auch bei der afg
galt ist heute ein führungsduo zu
bestimmen und es ist alles so gelaufen
wie es sich alexander gauland der
78-jährige scheidende co-vorsitzende
vorgestellt hat sein nachfolger an der
parteispitze wird die 44 jährige sachse
tino copala der andere co vorsitzende
jörg mountain setzte sich klar gegen
zwei mitbewerber durch nicole diekmann
berichtet er bleibt parteichef jörg
leuten wiedergewählt mit knapp 70
prozent
die überraschung ist es gibt bisher
keine große überraschung auf diesem
parteitag über den im vorfeld nicht mal
parteifunktionäre prognosen hatten
abgeben wollen oyten der für afg
verhältnisse als gemäßigt gilt
überzeugte
delegierten mit einer realpolitischen
rede die erneute amtszeit die ich heute
anstrebe soll die zwingend notwendige
professionalisierung bis zur wirklichen
regierungsfähigkeit vorantreiben und
auch noch vorsitzender steht fest die
lokaler setzte sich in einer stichwahl
gegen gottfried curio durch
innenpolitischer sprecher der fdp
fraktion
ob alaba wunschkandidat ist nun
abtretende parteichefs gauland und ist
malermeister aus sachsen mit ihm erringe
die starken ostdeutschen
fdp-landesverbände wehrmacht in der
partei ein historisches zeichen zu
setzen eine doppelspitze mit vertretern
aus west und ost
lange war spekuliert worden ob ihr ein
höcker als parteichef kandidieren würde
werke ist eine führende figur des
sogenannten völkisch nationalistischen
flügels der vom verfassungsschutz als
prüfer beobachtet wird seine wahl hätte
die partei wohl weiter nach rechts
gerückt herpes nein geht aber erstmal
nur für diesen parteitag
ich habe jederzeit die möglichkeit meine
stimme zu erheben und so wird
deutschlandweit gehört ich muss nicht
bundesvorsitzender dieser partei sei
nicht für das was dieser partei nutzt
und werde vielleicht auch mal für dieses
amt kandidieren wenn ich die zeit für
reif halte derzeit nun laufen die
stellvertreter wahlen auch sie gelten
als richtungsweisend für die fdp
delegierten sind der linie der
parteiführung also weitgehend gefolgt
für uns in braunschweig ist matthias
fornoff häuser da ist matthias was
bedeutet die wahl von tino copala an die
fdp-spitze für die partei
naja der partei patriarch alexander
gauland er hat seinen kronprinzen krupp
aller hier durchgesetzt wenn auch mit
mittelprächtigen ergebnis damit ist ein
generationswechsel vollzogen ohne
erkennbaren bruch und ein stück proporz
umgesetzt denn die doppelspitze der
partei die besteht jetzt aus dem
westdeutschen professor erneuten und dem
ostdeutschen malermeister kubala der war
auch für viele rechtsaußen selber ohne
selbst dem völkischen sogenannten flügel
anzugehören inhaltliche diskussionen hat
es hier in braunschweig übrigens bisher
kaum gegeben
die tiefen risse in der afg sind
übertüncht aber weiter vorhanden dass
die partei zur bürgerlichen mitte gehört
wie sie immer wieder selbst behauptet
muss das neue führungsduo nachweisen
sonst ist die afg eben weiterhin keine
alternative für regierungsbeteiligungen
in den ländern oder gar im bund vielen
dank matthias nach braunschweig nach
london
einen tag nach der messerattacke weiß
man dass der täter ein verurteilter
terrorist war der vorzeitig aus der haft
entlassen wurde
nach nicht einmal der hälfte der
haftzeit und ausgerechnet bei einer
veranstaltung zum thema resozialisierung
erstach er eine frau und einen mann
bevor er auf der landen bridge
überwältigt und von einem polizisten
erschossen wurde
aus london diana zimmermann mit einem
feuerlöscher und dem cern eines damals
wurden sie zu helden zwei zivilisten die
den attentäter in schach hielten bis die
polizei eintraf
die handlungen der polizei und der
zivilisten sind umso bemerkenswerter da
wir jetzt wissen dass der attentäter
eine täuschend echt wirkende selbstmord
weste trug die sich inzwischen als
attrappe herausgestellt hat
klar ist nun auch das aus man kann kein
unbekannter war 2012 wurde er wegen
eines geplanten bombenanschlags auf die
londoner börse verurteilt im jahr 2008
hatte die bbc den damals 17 jährigen
interviewt
ich bin kein terrorist ein unterricht im
dezember 2018 kam kann auf bewährung
frei er trug eine elektronische
fußfessel
gestern besuchte er die konferenz eines
resozialisierungsprogramm es für
gefängnisinsassen 100 teilnehmer waren
in der fisch mangas hole an der landen
bridge als er damit drohte das gebäude
in die luft zu sprengen
auf anwesende die sich ihm in den weg
stellten stadt kann mit zwei messern 1
ein polnischer küchenmitarbeiter riss
einen arbeits- hahn von der wand der
halle
er und ein verurteilter mörder ebenfalls
gast der veranstaltung verfolgten kann
auf die brücke wo die polizei ihn
erschoss zwei menschen starben an ihren
stichwunden drei weitere sind verletzt
es ist wahlkampf in großbritannien der
premier zeigte sich am tatort sehr
entschlossen
für uns als gesellschaft macht es keinen
sinn terror verurteilte frühzeitig zu
entlassen sie müssen ihre strafe
komplett absetzen
die polizei durchsuchte das haus von aus
man kann ins der fischer es wird davon
ausgegangen dass er als einzeltäter
gehandelt hat auch nach dem
messerangriff im niederländischen den
haag hat die polizei einen verdächtigen
gefasst
es handle sich um einen 35-jährigen mann
ohne festen wohnsitz
dies gab die polizei vor knapp einer
stunde bekannt
er soll gestern abend in einer
einkaufsstraße auf drei jugendliche
eingestochen haben
inzwischen konnten alle drei das
krankenhaus wieder verlassen
das motiv der tat ist noch völlig unklar
große anti braunkohle protest heute in
der lausitz tausende haben in
brandenburg und sachsen demonstriert und
mehrere tagebaue zwischenzeitlich
lahmgelegt hunderte aktivisten besetzten
die abbaugebiete jänschwalde welzow süd
und schleenhain aufgerufen hatte die
bewegung ende gelände
sie fordert sofort raus aus der kohle
wird ihn erwarten bericht
am frühen morgen dringen die
demonstranten auf das gelände des
tagebaus vor der polizei gelingt es
nicht sie daran zu hindern
zudem schafften es die protestierenden
die bahngleise zum kraftwerk jänschwalde
zu blockieren und so den kohle nachschub
zu verhindern
der kraftwerksbetreiber musste den
betrieb drosseln und die stromproduktion
einschränken
wir haben unsere ankündigung dass wir
heute hier das lausitzer kohlerevier
lahm legen heute wahr gemacht
die verler wunder im tagebau jänschwalde
stehen stelle hier fährt kein zug mehr
das ist unser schritt wie wir den
kohleausstieg selbst in die hand nehmen
nachdem die bundesregierung das ganze
letzte jahr versagt hat das
braunkohlekraftwerk jänschwalde gilt als
eines der ältesten und
klimaschädlichsten in europa ein
konkretes datum wann es vom netz gehen
soll gibt es noch nicht dagegen
protestierten heute 1000 in der lausitz
an der demonstration beteiligte sich
auch die schüler bewegung frei dsv
future sie fordern einen schnelleren
ausstieg aus der kohle bei der besetzung
des tagebaus dagegen blieb es nicht
durchgängig friedlich unsere
polizeibeamten sind dort unvermittelt
angegriffen wurden unsere polizeibeamten
mussten sich mit pfefferspray und
schlagstöcken gegen diese angriffe
wehren und es sind dabei eben drei
polizeibeamte verletzt wurden
am frühen morgen hatten sich mitarbeiter
des energiekonzerns lag vor dem werk
versammelt für sie bedeutet der ausstieg
aus der kohle den verlust von fast
20.000 arbeitsplätzen hallstatt in
österreich gehört zum weltkulturerbe
in der nacht hat ein großbrand dort
mehrere historische gebäude beschädigt
das feuer brach in einer holzhütte aus
und griff auf angrenzende häuser über
die bewohner konnten sich rechtzeitig in
sicherheit bringen ein feuerwehrmann
wurde bei dem einsatz verletzt
warum es brannte ist unklar karlstadt
ist berühmt für das älteste salzbergwerk
der welt der ort zieht mehr als eine
million besucher pro jahr an
der süden afrikas wird aktuell von einer
schweren dürre geplagt besonders
betroffen ist simbabwe millionen
menschen dort warten verzweifelt auf
regen
die vereinten nationen warnen durch
ernteausfälle haben viele nicht genug zu
essen
es droht eine große hungersnot die
trockenheit bedroht auch die tierwelt in
national park sind bereits viele
elefanten verdurstet aus dem berg pappe
berichtet sandra verhungert und
verdurstet direkt am wasserloch es
trifft vor allem junge und schwache
tiere
sie haben im kampf um das wenige wasser
keine chance seit september sind in
simbabwe rund 200 elefanten aufgrund der
dürre verendet wir haben auf antrags auf
gift und andere krankheiten getestet
alle tests waren negativ
will da rein konnten wir ausschließen
wenn alle kadaver die wir gefunden haben
die dürre verschärft auch den konflikt
zwischen mensch und tier auf der suche
nach nahrung und wasser laufen die
elefanten verstärkt in die siedlungen
und töten wer sich ihnen in den weg
stellt vor einem monat hat ein elefant
wie die cocos kusa getötet auch er
selbst wurde schon angegriffen
[Musik]
ich habe gespürt wie der elefant seinen
stoß zahlen durch meinen rechten
oberschenkel gestoßen hat dann hat er
mich durch die luft geschleudert
er überlebte wie durch ein wunder in den
vergangenen zwei wochen hat es
vereinzelt geregnet seitdem wird es
grüner für manche zu spät damit die
ausgemergelten tiere wieder genug
nahrung finden wird noch sehr viel mehr
regen fallen müssen
zum sport zwei gegner kennt joachim löw
jetzt nach der auslosung zur fußball
europameisterschaft aber man kann sagen
schon jetzt eine hammergruppe norbert
oder absolut es sind wirklich zwei teams
der absoluten extraklasse weltmeister
frankreich wartet gleich zum auftakt
außerdem geht es gegen den europameister
portugal mit superstar cristiano ronaldo
den dritten gruppengegner kennen wir
erst ende märz
das sprichwörtliche losglück hat
deutschland diesmal nicht frankreich
lebt mit ihrem star antoine griezmann
der weltmeister das dfb team hat keine
allzu guten erinnerungen an die
franzosen sie haben die deutschen titel
träume 2016 im halbfinale beendet und
dann zieht ausgerechnet philipp lahm
auch noch den europameister portugal
das team rund um superstar cristiano
ronaldo die mannschaft die gegen
frankreich im em-finale vor vier jahren
den titel geholt hat und auch wenn der
letzte gruppengegner für die vorrunde in
münchen erst im märz in den playoffs
ermittelt wird schon jetzt ist klar es
ist die schwerste vorrundengruppe lisa m
mit einem fehlstart beginnen für jürgen
klinsmann der trainerjob in berlin die
hertha verliert daheim gegen borussia
dortmund trotz zahlreicher chancen in
der schlussphase unterliegt hier hat er
mit eins zu zwei auch paderborn mit
einer heimniederlage 2 zu 3 gegen rb
leipzig dazu zwei mal eins zu eins
hennings sichert düsseldorfs punkt in
hoffenheim kurz vor schluss genauso
kölns cordoba in der partie gegen den fc
augsburg am abend die bayern gegen
leverkusen
ausführlich im sportstudio gestern
schalke gegen union 22 12 spiele morgen
1 am montag eine tabelle als
momentaufnahme gladbach und die bayern
haben die chance leipzig wieder von der
spitze zu holen wolfsburg oder
leverkusen könnte in die zweite hälfte
abrutschen
für union bleibt es trotz der niederlage
gestern bei fünf punkten vorsprung auf
den relegationsplatz mainz und werder
noch mit einem spiel weniger von den
letzten dreien hat nur köln ein
pünktchen geholt
zu gast im aktuellen sportstudio um 23
uhr ist routinier neven subotic vom
starken aufsteiger union berlin
prima start für deutschlands handball
frauen in die weltmeisterschaft in japan
30 zu 24 gegen brasilien
herausragende spielerin war torfrau
diener eckerle vom deutschen meister
bietigheim sie parierte 17 würfe
darunter drei siebenmeter
nach dem unerwartet klaren auftaktsieg
sind morgen zwei punkte fest eingeplant
gegen außenseiter australien und die
biathlon saison ist eröffnet mit den
ersten team wettbewerben in östersund in
schweden erik lesser mit klarem
vorsprung vor dem letzten schießen
vergab mit einer strafrunde den
möglichen auftaktsieg im duett mit
franziska preuß
im ziel hatte das deutsche single
mixteam dann 18 sekunden rückstand auf
das schwedische duo samuelsson ölberg
anschließend musste sich die deutsche
mixed-staffel im quartett mit platz
sieben begnügen
schon mal ein bisschen winter danke
norbert zum wetter im südwesten kann es
zum ersten advent etwas schneien und
regnen sonst scheint auch mal die sonne
zu den einzelheiten gleich gunther
tiersch so viele von uns an diesem
samstag um 22 45 freut sich marietta
slomka mit dem heute journal auf sie
danke für ihr interesse und noch einen
gemütlichen samstagabend für sie bis
morgen tschüss
[Musik]
guten abend liebe zuschauer morgen
schneit es im südwesten etwas dafür ist
es kalt genug aber schaut man sich mal
die temperaturen des herbstes an die
abweichungen
dann war dieser herbst von september bis
november zu milch oder zu warm ein bis
zwei grad wärmer als normal also das
klima verändert sich bei uns weiterhin
jetzt haben wir paar kalte tage und das
bedeutet in dieser nacht klaren himmel
nebelfelder vor allen dingen
norddeutschland und im laufe der nacht
auch zunehmende bewölkung hier im
südwesten es wird fast überall frostig
temperaturen morgen früh 0 bis -5 grad
vielleicht minus acht grad auch im
erzgebirge und auch tagsüber es kühler
als heute
es sind meist so zwischen 1 und 6 grad
und zum teil gibt es leichten dauerfrost
in süddeutschland ja das wetter in
norddeutschland wird ziemlich trüb dabei
ab und zu vielleicht mal ein paar
sonnenstrahlen an den küsten aber auch
ein paar tropfen regen sind möglich dann
erst wieder an den mittelgebirgen so vom
niederrhein bis ins südliche brandenburg
sachsen da kommt die sonne raus ähnlich
wie heute genauso wie im östlichen
bayern aber nach westen hin dass schneit
eben westlich des rheins während es hier
so im schwarzwald schwäbischer alb nur
oberhalb von 500 meter schneit darunter
wird es regen sein und die aussichten
ist bleibt kühl in dieser woche noch und
in der nächsten woche vor allen dingen
norddeutschland bleibt eher trüb im
süden scheint man die sonne
ich wünsche noch einen schönen abend und
machen sie's gut